well
I think
oh sorry
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everyone great to join
you today so five years ago today nine
innocent parishioners of a historically
black church were killed during an
evening Bible study in Charleston South
Carolina we all remember that tragedy
and this was a despicable act of evil
that happened five years ago today so we
remember that somber day at that
Charleston Church as our hearts still
break for the victims and our prayers go
out to the families yesterday president
Trump led and brought our nation
together behind a real meaningful
substantial change to ensure that we
have safe streets and safe policing part
of that was having an incentive
structure to implement the highest
professional standards in our Police
Department's through an accreditation
process this accreditation entails
making sure you have de-escalation
practices in place use of force tactics
in place part of that is prohibiting
chokeholds except in the event where
lethal force is used it also
incentivizes information sharing and
makes sure that if you have an officer
who's had multiple uses of excessive
force that that information is sent to a
national database and then finally
another prong of this was having Co
responders
spent officials often have to deal with
mental health homelessness and addiction
and having a co responder who is an
expert in this process on will go a long
way this is project progress it's
tangible action and its solutions
as President Trump said yesterday all
children deserves an equal opportunity
because we are all made by God that is
so true first let me point out that I
have sat across from a police officer
family that lost their loved one I saw a
little girl named Charlie who will
forever grow up without a father he will
forever grow up without a father for
prom for the father-daughter dance it
was heartbreaking to know that she lost
her father who was a valiant hero but
yesterday I sat across from families who
lost their loved ones and mass instances
of injustice and it was heartbreaking
it was a real moment when the good
president when I asked him the Oval
Office about afterwards he said this I
love those families I want to help those
families and presidents from from means
that because this is about found
management that is ultimately of what
what this is about
and Senator Scott shared a very
beautiful Bible verse with those
families yesterday and I just want to
read it here to close Romans 8:28 and we
know that in all things God works for
the good of those who love Him who have
been called according to his purpose
he shared that Bible verse with those
families and it was particularly
meaningful to me and I think to the
families as well and with that I'll take
questions yes great job doing about the
feedback I know that's not it's - is the
war yes thank you all right so the top
administration the front Justice
Department has appointed six US
attorneys to examine the actions of the
president's political adversaries but
they've only opened one federal
investigation into
the president and his allies were
treated fairly by law enforcement and
not the same three millions of black man
so I think you're comparing two things
that it's not accurate to compare on the
level of the number of attorneys making
big lies funded by Hillary Clinton and
the Democrats it was an injustice to the
American people who elected President
Trump as president of the United States
endemically had to artificially shut
down the economy you can fix the
individual pieces but it's up to our
country to change hearts yes
they are working closely on that and our
Elio puts an end to that or incentivizes
through the accreditation process to put
it into choke holds in the unless there
is lethal force news we fully support
the Scottsdale and every element of it
and one thing I would note about the
Scott bill is for years we've tried to
make lynching a federal crime in this
country and the Scottsdale does it's a
great bill it's more great action from
Republicans and we hope we can have
bipartisan support on that so what I
would I have from the Justice act here
is that this will also in the practice
of utilizing the chokeholds and I would
underscore the executive order does that
through and incentivizing process so
we've done what we can and we'll
continue to do more and we'll continue
to work with the Scott Bell and there
might be amendments to it there might
not but we want to see this come to
fruition yes well that is where we're
incentivizing to ban chokeholds and less
than in a case of simpler lethal force
is used that's the process that we're
using and I'll tell you this it's a much
better process and the Democrats who so
far have offer zero nothing except a lot
of bad ideas about this now what
ultimately I would know to fund the
police department yes
wondering about this rally coming
Saturday well the president the White
House so the campaign has taken certain
measures on to make sure this is safe
rally temperature checks hand sanitizers
and math so we are taking precautions
they will be given a mask it's up to
them whether to make that decision CDC
guidelines are recommended but not
required it's personal choice of
individuals asked what would you but if
we want to talk about internal coherence
I believe that the media needs to work
on internal coherence this is wonderful
New York Post story I don't think
Stephen L sounds here but good job for
New York coast highlights the hypocrisy
of the media where this is okay
protesting this is not okay Trump
rallies it's really remarkable and I
think the American people have taken
notice when for instance to NBC tweets
at 4:05 p.m. on June 14th rally for
black trans lives drawers packed crowd
to Brooklyn Museum Plaza seemed the
seeming to be lauding the protest Minh
West in an hour and half later they say
president from plans to rally but health
experts are questioning that decision
CBS had a similar logically inconsistent
tweet
be demonstration for any kind of causes
and supporting the president and I go
back to my original question will the
White House will the president take
responsibility if there are people can
catch the corona virus and get sex so
have you by the way yes yes pre-existing
conditions that might put them at risk
was for serious complications if they
catch this fire so first let me know
using three of our country and paychecks
going up we rally that HBCU funding for
historically black colleges and
universities is permanent because the
president transport we rally but to say
no because you Jamie suggested you
suggested that I don't rally on behalf
of anything so let me know one more
thing we rally on behalf of we rally on
behalf of criminal justice reform in the
first step back which President Obama
and Vice President Biden talked about
what we did and I would note this if we
want to talk about the efficacy of what
we're doing 1,300 health experts signed
a letter about the protest saying we do
not condemn these gatherings we support
them as vital so you have the health
experts on one side saying this and then
all of a sudden a trump rally is
different and I've taken five of your
questions
work on your internal cohesion and get
back
and last I I said to you weird a fashion
I said you were taking precautions math
hand sanitizer
we are doing temperature checks and
sanitizers masks when you come to the
rally as it's any event you assume a
personal risk on that is just what you
do when you go to a baseball game you
assume a risk that's part of life it's
the personal decision of Americans as to
whether to go to the rally or whether
not to go to the rally but I would note
that this concern for the rallies has
been largely absent when it came to the
protesters people really notes on when
CBS says thousands participate in a
rally and a silent march for black trans
lives and then less than this more than
hour and half later president from
moving ahead with the rally serious risk
of spreading coronavirus it's really
inconsistent the media seems to not be
interested in health so much as ideology
behind certain events so you know for
instance you go and the lockdown
protesters were widely condemned by the
media who were protesting the lockdown
then all of a sudden those protests with
black lives matter is lauded it makes no
sense ideology is driving the line of
questioning in many of these cases when
it should be if you're focused on
science you should be out there asking
the same questions about the protest
it's their personal decision as to
whether they want to get tested after
but I'd note some testing capability is
thanks to president Trump twenty three
point seven million people tested in
this country so far that's an
extraordinary number so testings out
there and available if someone chooses
to do that Jen so the president is aware
of it we're monitoring the situation
between Indian and Chinese forces along
the line of actual control and eastern
Ladakh so we've seen that the Indian
Army statement that twenty Indian
soldiers died as a result of the
confrontation today and
the coronavirus task force on there me w
a I would first point that out they meet
regularly and they monitor the whole
country self though they don't own it on
a trolley they zone it on the whole
country and analyze it through a
database lens they look at the entirety
of the country that would improve the
state of Oklahoma but they look at all
50 states in close consultation with
governor's you know it's something
that's being looked at of course that
phase four and no announcements on what
those elements would be and would want
to get out ahead of the president but I
would note that this economy is robust
and growing and coming back stronger
than anyone could think from this
because of the president I mean you look
at retail sales surging 17.7%
unemployment insurance weekly claims
falling we have the fastest growth rate
in American history in the third quarter
so we artificially shut down the economy
but we have a robust recovery happening
and taking place and that's thanks to
President Trump and there are a lot of
good metrics like new business
applications skyrocketing small
businesses now opening at about 80
percent Apple mobility index that's
practically pre-pandemic levels so
there's more work to be done a face war
will address that should it take place
but we are encouraged by what we're
seeing that the Donald Trump economy is
coming back because ultimately investors
and business owners have faith in this
president yes Jeff
that there would be no more virtually no
cases left that doesn't make sense
yeah it's entirely logical when you do
more testing you identify more cases
countries that don't do as much testing
don't identify the same number of cases
I mean it's pretty logical exactly what
he said no that that was then that was
not at all what he was saying he was
saying when you test you end up
identifying more cases and we've tested
23.7 million people positivity rate of
5.9% so we are in a good place when it
comes to testing
[Music]
the White House is confident that we
have enough testing to identify
asymptomatic individuals that we have
therapeutics that are promising that we
are working on a vaccine with project
warp-speed that we hope will be there by
the end of the year and we think will be
and we have a robust public-private
partnership that a short of America's
supply chain so we are in a good place
and that's what the vice-president was
known and junked really two subjects the
first question has to do with the
lawsuit that was filed against john
bolton the former national security
adviser by the Department of Justice
yesterday
the DOJ did so that as to why they went
down that particular path that's the
question for DOJ but what I would note
is this book is full of classified
information which is inexcusable former
national security adviser John Bolton
should know all too well that it's
unacceptable to have highly classified
information from the government of the
United States in a book that will be
published it's unacceptable it has not
gone through the review process and
that's where we currently stand and I'd
refer you back to bars comment on this
which is we don't believe that Bolton
went through that process it hasn't been
completed the process and therefore he
is in violation of that agreement that
was part of his quote from Monday
subject the executive order of the
President signed yesterday during that
event and his comments he acknowledged
that there are indeed that police
officers is the president opposed to the
idea of removing qualified immunity for
police officers even bad
yes so qualified immunity let me know it
is a total and complete non-starter what
qualified immunity would do is it would
really enable the police in this country
to do their job that's when the Democrat
bill and I'd argue this you know
Democrats they Sayed to fund the police
to fund the police we hear that from
congresswoman Acacio Cortez and
congresswoman Omar and others well what
is the Democrat bill do by removing
qualified immunity what you're
essentially doing is not allowing police
to do their job there would be a
decrease in policing in this country our
streets would not be safe what President
Trump has done is worked with law
enforcement to improve law enforcement
to ensure that the the bad cops that
exists are pushed out of the system the
overwhelming majority of cops are good
so we've got to address the the handful
that are bad and that's what the
president's order has done but taking
away qualified immunity would make the
streets of this country a whole lot less
secure just look at what happened when
we didn't have ample law enforcement out
on Lafayette Square a church burned and
multiple officers injured look I would
note that also the court has litigated
this um pretty strongly it's been
adjudicated the harlow courts in that
decision Harlow the supreme court talked
about achieving a balance between
allowing victims to hold officials
accountable while also men of minimizing
the social cost to the whole the costs
of police officers for example pulling
back so the Supreme Court has litigated
this for decades
I mean as approached what they think is
the appropriate balance with qualified
immunity and I think it would go a long
way just doing what the president did
yesterday having that national database
of offender so we ensure that a police
officer doesn't leave one department and
then go to another
Franchesca
his position on qualified immunity
defending the police but you also said
earlier that the Democratic bill is full
of bad ideas what are the other full
unquote bad ideas besides miss to but
the president would not sign a lease
until they wound up in the final version
so one of the things on the dole does if
it undermines due process the Democrat
bill would undermine the due process
rights of every officer by making
pending and unsubstantial allegations
available to the public causing
reputational reputational damage based
on allegations alone that's a really
good example because when our database
does is once a claim has been
adjudicated we know something was done
wrong it goes into a database that
remains private it protects privacy of
the officers but it is utilized to
ensure that officer does not get to go
to another department what the Democrat
bill would do is someone submits an
allegation well we're gonna violate the
due process rights of this officer and
put it into a system we have to balance
everything in this situation making sure
our good hard-working overwhelmingly
good police officers are able to do
their job but ensuring that we do not
have victims like the victims I heard
about yesterday and the excruciatingly
painful devastating stories of their
sisters of their mothers and of their
fathers one of the curse on that is
something else
so you're saying those are the three
that's it there's a number of things but
those are the ones that I've listed out
so far there's a number and on the
president's rally he is also so that he
has rallies on the books in North
Carolina and also Florida two states
that have seen recent spikes in
coronavirus who told the president that
it would be safe to have rallies in
states that are seeing spikes rating
we're confident that there are embers
out there that exists that will be able
to put out those embers Florida is a
great governor he's done a great job so
far we work closely with governor
DeSantis and we believe that we will be
at a safe place yes
for justice courses decision from the
Supreme Court this week against anti
LGBT discrimination was focused on
employment civil rights law but also
implications on housing health care what
part of the president wants to
discipline it as you wanted to do as
extensively or as narrowly as possible
so what the president says is he's read
the decision they've ruled we live with
the decision and we live with the
decision of the Supreme Court so that's
where he stands currently and in terms
of how its implement implemented DOJ
will lead the multi-agency effort to
help provide certainty to the regulated
parties opportunity to and to be much
like President Obama in 2013 said he
hope the marriage decision from the
Supreme Court would be implemented as
extensively as possible what does
president Trump's view on the
appropriate scope of courses decisions
so DOJ will be guiding that entirely so
I will leave that to DOJ doesn't have
any conversations with a DOJ about the
implication about the decision not that
I'm aware of you might have had when I
don't know about that not that no
question does the president think that
being for the Bostic decision is a
window civil-rights sorry does the
president think the coarsest decision as
they went for civil rights so one thing
I would say I haven't not talked to the
president about that personally but one
thing I wanted to read was from the
Cavanaugh dissent there were some real
concerns that this was a complete
distortion of how we do statutory
interpretation and Cavan always that out
very nicely
but one thing justice Kavanagh did say
and I thought it was a very powerful
quote is notwithstanding my concern
about the courts transgression of the
Constitution separation of powers which
was a grave concern as a separation of
powers point that the DOJ but the DOJ
argued in court it is appropriate to
acknowledge the important victory
achieved today on by gay and lesbian
Americans so I thought that that was a
very good quote from justice Kavanaugh
yeah
and the plans would use US troops in
Germany is there a timeline you can
share with us and could this decision
this plan be change or softened if
Berlin agreed to increase its defense
spending so the president addressed some
our presence American troop presence in
Germany and he said we're bringing that
number down from 52,000 about what it's
at now to 25,000 and the rationale for
that he articulated was that Germany is
very delinquent in their payments to
NATO they're paying 1% they are supposed
to be at 2% and even 2% is low it should
be much more than that
my co-teacher if Germany agrees and we
get it ahead of the President on making
that decision Michael thanks daily I
have one question I have two quick
questions from colleagues who have sent
to me as the pool person so on my
question back when to White House
officials were tested tested positive
for kovat there we all reported on an
email that went out to West Wing
employees instructing them that masks
were mandatory to be worn in the West
Wing at all times with the exception of
being when they were sitting at their
desks alone obviously none of the White
House people that I've been wearing
masks at all
has that been rescinded has that it has
that instruction to West Wing employees
been rescinded
formally or is it just still in place
but nobody's paying attention to it or
masks are recommended but not required
required excuse me do two quick
questions yeah I want to get to everyone
in the room so these are for people who
can't be in the room because of the
restrictions I understand but I want to
make sure I get to everyone in the room
and then we can come back so Rob can I
just get a complication on your
equivalence between protests in the
streets and riot sub-state is it the
White House position that outdoor events
carry the same risk as indoor events
it's our position that the media should
not be making decisions about their
their guidelines to us about social
distancing based on political ideology
or what they think is the worthiness of
the point is there a good scientific
reasons
Treaty two events different one is
outdoors and women's indoors right and
there's not good logical reason for this
so that's the one thing I would keep
going back to yes always anything about
the Secretary of State's and the trip to
the white Chinese counterpart so I have
no information on that Owen yes you to a
couple of the economic front earlier
this month in Maine the president was
talking about Maine lobster and he said
the following he said the European Union
doesn't drop that tariff immediately
we're gonna put a tariff on their cars
which will be equivalent you give us an
update on that what is immediately what
is the status of potential tariffs on
sea waters I haven't inquired about that
today but I will inquire about that and
I'll try to get back to you before 5:00
if that works and secondly an
infrastructure bill can you just sort of
give us a broad outline of what the
administration wants to see is that a
reauthorization of the highway bill that
comes up at the end of the year is that
added on to a potential base for
stimulus what is the administration what
is the White House want I don't want to
get ahead of the administration on our
official plans for that infrastructure
something we've talked about for a long
time and it's something that we think
that we could find common ground on but
it's up to Democrats to really come to
us and make that happen it's been
mentioned as potentially a phase four
but that's not in stone on but that has
been mentioned no formalized plans
though on where infrastructure stands
trillion dollars we don't have a number
on that right now yes
health experts the campaign and the
White House consulted before deciding to
hold it do they
well we are taking every single safety
precaution that we can and again I would
note this is probably question number 10
on rallies and while we appreciate the
great concern for our rally goers um you
should exhibit that same concern for the
protesters who are out there who are not
socially distancing in many cases and
not wearing masks
shanell on China and India you just
mentioned the administration is
monitoring the situation by the
president was mentioned that he would be
willing to mediate the tent that
conflict between China and India now if
you were to do so what does that look
like does that mean does that look like
a one-on-one conversation does that mean
bringing the two leaders together has
the president indicated what mediation
looks like for China and India so again
no no formal plans will not be on what I
already said in expressing our absolute
condolences to the Indian soldiers that
died as a result of today's
confrontation we extend our deepest
condolences there and I would note just
that during the phone call on june 2nd
of this year that President Trump had
with Prime Minister Modi they did
discuss the situation on the India China
border relationship between President
Trump and President Xi the Chinese
forces have been moving thousands of
troops to that region that it doesn't
seem like that region was going to see
anytime soon if you were to characterize
president Trump's relationship with
President Xi today well yeah my to
venture into that realm I I would just
say what the president has said before
that he is really appalled at the fact
that the of the coronavirus came out of
China they weren't allowing flights into
China but were allowing flights out they
slow-walked information the w-h-o seemed
to partner with China and slow-walking
that information about asymptomatic the
president is very upset by that action
of China or inaction in some cases I
should say thank you all very much today
and I hope we start seeing more
consistent headlines very much
yeah
I have characterized this pandemic as a
crisis of health a crisis of the economy
and a social crisis in the American